welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information
on about copying your friends moves and
how that can not only make you better
on the dance floor but also lead to a
really successful
career i'm a little horse tommy bechtold
because i screamed too loud on the
fourth of july and i'm here today with
my peaches and cream
big head game day one number one man
mt what's up baby how you doing big heck
[Music]
were you really uh screaming yesterday
yes i was poolside
shouting like a madman i was trying to
compete with the fireworks
every time one would uh every time one
would go off i would just shout at it
like the taskmaster i was mimicking the
sounds of fireworks
all right obviously we're talking black
widow today we gotta we gotta we gotta
do it literally
they're making us uh no uh we want to
we're happy to go
again this is your one and only spoiler
warning if you have not seen
black widow yet hit pause on this video
right now
you need to go to the cinema get
yourself some popcorn
put some m ms in the popcorn shake the
bag
mix it all together thank me later okay
[Laughter]
log into your disney plus account or
your cousin's disney plus account
or your ex girlfriend's disney plus
account but just don't judge what
they've already watched
because you know some people like to
watch the fox and the hound every night
of their lives
you know how i'm talking today man
personally i can't fall asleep without
the sounds of high school musical too
that's right i like high school musical
the musical
uh because the title is ridiculous
anyway the high school musical the
musical
series this year that's right yes and
then after that you need to come back
here and hit play and watch the rest of
this video
all right so we are talking black widow
today specifically
the skull master fighter with all the
classic moves that's right
task master we finally saw taskmaster
make the leap from the comics
to the big screen but how are they able
to copy the fighting style
of some of our favorite heroes it all
leads up to this week's big question
empty how does taskmaster's tech work so
in the comics the title of taskmaster
was held by anthony masters and he of
course had
photographic reflexes that enabled him
to watch someone's moves and
100 replicate them immediately without
any practice which is
pretty great i wish i could do that i
can't i can barely remember
how to say words but of course instead
of using these powers for good like any
good boy like you and me which is
extreme we are forced for good
we would always use our powers for good
yeah peaches and cream are actually our
vigilante for crime fighting names
that's right coming to cw
coming to the cw peaches and um
for no i think it's more of an hbo max
man yeah by the name you know
yeah you're right yeah this is tbma
but yes instead of using these powers
for good he chose a life of crime and
often found himself
at odds with heroes like captain america
spider-man
wolverine daredevil iron man ant-man and
reed richards
just to name a few even though i feel
like that was a lot of people just now
anyway yeah just to name a few the the
main seven
the main seven freaking avengers well
maybe not
man sorry man but he also made a living
by setting up training centers in order
to teach other bad guys
how to fight their favorite avengers so
if anyone has a beef with daredevil it's
like you know what
uh guess what guys i think he's blind
here's a hot tip he can't see this is
kind of
this makes me think of like when old men
like when dads go to like rock camp to
learn how to play guitar
like keith richards like it's like
taskmaster will you
you can send your dad to camp to fight
his enemy like if
your dad has a huge beef with hercules
send him to uh taskmaster's camp
oh my god that'd be so funny it's like
hey do you want to want to fight the
bully at school
learn how to be like him fight like him
and then beat him with his own technique
yes exactly okay but the mcu of course
has gone a very different direction with
taskmaster because it's been revealed
that drakov's daughter antonia was the
one
and only taskmaster of the mcu and
having barely survived the blast set off
by black widow
in order to kill drake off antonio was
saved and turned into the mimicking
menace known as the taskmaster but how
does she even do it
let's dive into that evidence provided
by the film to see if we can't
figure out the secret behind her copycat
technique yes first of all we know that
she likes to
study some game tape because when we
first see the taskmaster
she's studying some game tape of hawkeye
and black panther fighting at the
airport during the events of civil war
and the recording is from the overhead
angle so it's clear that drakov was
spying on this action or
it seems that way anyway and maybe even
directly from his red room flying base
right which would make sense considering
that it is overhead in that red room uh
it definitely uh definitely be up there
in the skies in the clouds
with the lord but you would think that
they would learn by now it's like i feel
like
flying bases like you're doomed to just
fall out of the sky
did you not see winter soldier yeah
you're right and i'm also kind of like
wait so no one ever detected that
like no no no one ever accidentally like
flew into it
exactly i'm like this is a pretty
massive thing i'm like they always say
oh yeah we got cloaking tech
we can't see us i'm like it's pretty big
it's pretty pink i've got to say
but let's not forget a lot of our heroes
have signature moves that they repeat
over and over again and elena
often jokes about natasha's hero landing
which i found like one of my favorite
parts of the movie is just
it's so true like i've always wondered
like why does she always do that
dramatic like
i don't know like the i can't even do it
from here it's like the yeah
split you know like yeah if i ever tried
that my back would literally
snap and twain absolutely i would be
paralyzed yes uh immediately
but of course having these signature
moves makes it easier for taskmaster to
see what's coming so maybe
a little less flourish and a little more
just off the cuff you know what i'm
saying just gotta
yes gotta keep it gotta keep it fresh
okay yeah so taskmaster don't see what's
coming you know gotta give him the one
two and then
three four after that you know
but also general drakov says that his
daughter is a mimic which also helps her
learn and replicate
different fighting styles now this could
be a sort of enhancement brought on by a
combination of the suit and the
implanted microchip
or she could have innate mimic abilities
similar to how clint barton has like a
natural perfect aim antonia could also
have
natural mimic abilities like maybe she
could even be a mutant she could be the
first mutant
that we've seen in the mcu which would
be super exciting but we could also
consider that drakov could have put some
genetic engineering into his own
daughter because he's a weirdo that way
right and he clearly has a lot of access
to all sorts of nefarious science and
technology as evidenced by those that
horrifying pig scene
i cannot believe that she did that to
those pigs like i don't even like
that she got redeemed by the end of the
movie redeemed i don't know i don't
trust that woman yeah
me either she's an animal torturer she's
i don't like her anyway that's just a
little weird aside
yeah and perhaps draco was messing
around with his own daughter's genetic
makeup and this could have even helped
her survive the explosion in budapest
because in the comics the anthony
masters version of taskmaster eventually
injects himself with a modified version
of the super soldier serum so perhaps
we'll discover that antonia was also
injected
with some sort of enhancement that has
yet to be determined
but let's talk about the suit because we
have the heads-up display of the suit
which is
pretty damn impressive especially the
assistance that the heads up display to
provides taskmaster
we got a couple of looks from
taskmaster's perspective in the movie
and much like tony's iron man suit
the wear is provided with a lot of
tactical information and this certainly
helps the taskmaster
match the fighting abilities of anyone
that she comes across in fact the tech
is actually
very similar to when iron man and
captain america came to blows in captain
america
civil war because tony instructs friday
to study cap's fighting style so that he
can keep up in a hand-to-hand fight
with the world's greatest supersoul
countermeasures ready
let's kill his ass
and the ai analyzes steve's fight
pattern and develops a plan of attack
for tony and we see a similar style of
analysis when taskmaster first attacks
black widow on the bridge in norway like
why would it be so similar well we know
that sometimes tony has some help with
the development of his technology and
he doesn't always do it on his own
because for example quentin beck from
spiderman far from home
he was the main engineer behind barf and
as you saw in spider-man far from home
he and some other disgruntled stark
employees wanted up stealing barf and
other stark technology to try to trick
the world
for their own personal gain by making
the world believe that mysterio was a
superhero
i don't know how long they were planning
on keeping that ruse up uh
that was inevitable that that was
inevitably going to fail because when
the avengers showed up they'd be like
yes this guy's not legit he doesn't have
powers no
no it's a fake now that we know that the
widows are embedded all around the world
it's possible that some of tony's fight
analysis technology was stolen
and wound up in drakov's hands so now
back to taskmaster's first confrontation
with black widow on the bridge we do get
a look at the heads up display to see
how taskmaster
views a threat the visor tracks the
target's key points
especially around the joints in order to
build a crude digital skeleton type
thing and this is very similar to motion
tracking technology
used in motion capture for movies
and this gives taskmaster a prediction
percentage of the target's next move
as well as a threat level and since we
know that taskmaster has the microchip
right inside of her brain
the reaction time can be instantaneous
and the hud
also keeps taskmaster on task which is
great because
i can't keep anything on task so i
probably need a chip in my brain to
help with this adhd there you go good
god i don't think my therapist can help
me anymore she's just like you just
too much maybe stop with the bang maybe
stop drinking bangs no problem
definitely
we would never stop drinking our beloved
sponsors
because when she realizes that natasha
isn't in possession of the target she
moves on from the text
sort of like the terminator she's like
don't need this chick i'm gonna go
directly for the package
and the hud also provides important
weapons information but we'll touch on
that in a second
but first let's talk some more about the
suit itself because we've already
discussed how the helmet provides a lot
of
important data as it constantly scans
the target but is the suit providing any
additional support
well it appears to be armored and a
little bit bulky and it's got armored
plating on some really key points
and this probably protects the wearer
from blunt force as well as damage from
blade attacks
and it would also provide some
protection from explosive damage
fire and probably some smaller caliber
bullets but
and when we do get the reveal of
antonia's phase we see the damage caused
by the fire and the explosion
and we can assume that her body suffered
severe damage all over as well
and this makes the possibility of the
suit providing some form of life support
similar to darth vader's iconic suit
more of a thing and if that's the case
then that makes the suit even more
important for taskmaster she was really
messed up
the fact that she's even alive after
that explosion is
impossible like natasha blew her the f
up right she should not be alive so
i wouldn't be surprised if the
taskmaster suit was a some type of
i can't take this off or else i'll i'll
wither away and die and perish
right like it's like a spanx it's just
holding her all together
but let's talk about her weapons and her
shield the shield is pretty tough though
i don't think it's vibranium it does
have that little hum you can hear when
it's in action
sort of like vibranium does but it's not
quite the same tone
as the vibranium is that vibranium um it
got a specific tone you know we're going
to get that right
that good wakandan right you know what
i'm saying
[Music]
it's a heavier sound and not as melodic
the shield is able to block small arms
fire and is pretty effective when thrown
though it doesn't always have the clean
bounce back that cap's vibranium shield
has
and it ain't like the real thing you
know what i'm saying anthony mackie got
the one and only
it's really nice and the backpack
appears to hold a variety of weapons
that are able to hold down and fit into
a compact compartment and during that
chase
through budapest we can see in
taskmaster's hud that there was a
variety of arrows that she could choose
from
and so the technology in these weapons
must be similar to the nanotechnology
that we've already seen in the mcu so
far
and objects are able to change as needed
and fold down into compact sizes
and we also see this technology on the
backpack weapons of the widows if you
look closely
and when using the bow and arrow during
the chase taskmaster suit provides
critical information
to make the perfect shot it shows the
distance the speed and other critical
tracking information and this ensures
that taskmaster cannot
miss knocking that bmw into the subway
corner pocket because
you need to do it when you need to do it
you know what i'm saying do it
taskmaster is a deficient woman you
don't mess around absolutely strong
independent
[Music]
and taskmaster also has some really
sharp claws similar to black panther
that she whips out when finding
red guardian i literally thought red
guardian was going to die in that scene
i was like
this is it they they're sort of setting
this up for a big death scene and uh
that was uh those claws are sharp so
this is it you about to get your throat
cut out
black panther style cultural
appropriation can't even believe it
that's everywhere god damn it everyone
everyone everyone wants to be like
wakanda all right that's right i don't
understand
[Music]
get your own thing taskmaster jeez maybe
after she saw the civil war fight at the
leipzig airport she decided she needed
to add some claws to her suit and she
also has a knife that she flips around
like the winter soldier
during that battle as well and the suit
also has a built-in parachute which is a
great idea especially when you have your
office
in the sky yes you know brilliant so in
conclusion i think it's safe to say that
taskmaster's abilities are a combination
of innate talent
plenty of time for studying and tech
assisting state-of-the-art
equipment but that's just a theory
a taskmaster theory yes about
a delightful theory now i you know empty
i loved what you said
about the possibility of her having some
serum injected into her some super
soldiers here
maybe even like a modified dose maybe
even as a child maybe
maybe that's how she survived the
explosion like you had said like
that would make sense to me and i wonder
if in the original draft maybe it was
explained that way and then they just
decided not to
like they decided they didn't need that
extra level of justification for how
a small child could survive that
explosion but i think
i think that that has to be it to me i i
think i
i do like the idea of the super serum
thing because like it would sort of
potentially tie into you know falcon in
the winter soldier stuff
um if they really wanted to make that
connection but um
you know it's it's i do think that she
could be a mutant i really like the idea
of her
being the first mutant that is
introduced in the mcu yeah
because dracov just calls her a mimic
right and the way that he says it i'm
like
is he saying it like she's just a mimic
from birth is he has she always been
a mimic it would be a really cool thing
if like the technology in her brain
like sort of just enhances her already
innate abilities you know it would also
tie into
you know why you know these these hydra
people were even doing research into the
brain
in the first place because i feel like
that was a very interesting
point of the movie it's like wow the
hydra is really trying to hack
the the free will of human beings but
yeah i i really
do want to think that she's the first
mutant but we haven't seen mutants yet
in the mcu
we shall we shall see only the time will
tell now we got to talk
a little bit about merch baby
if you like what we do here at new
rockstars and i think you do
you can show your support and help us
make more of the content we love by
going to newrockstarsmerch.com
you can pull taskmasters and mimic the
new rockstars hosts
by wearing the same t-shirts you see
eric and mt
and everyone else wearing the videos
except for me because i only have that
one
mandalorian shirt and i'm working on
getting a loki shirt but
philip says i have to do 100 push-ups so
it'll probably be a few months from now
you can even get a high i'm eric voster
which i like to wear to confuse my
family
uh which seems a little on the nose for
taskmaster but
still a very fun shirt to own so get
some great gear including hats
hoodies pins stickers and support
this channel by heading over to
newrockstarsmerch.com
now before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the folks
that help keep
big question coming to you first
starting with
mint mobile now after years of fine
print contracts and getting ripped off
by
big wireless providers we've learned
that there's always a catch so when we
heard that mint mobile offers premium
wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month we
thought what's the catch but with mint
there isn't a catch mint mobile secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only
so by cutting out retail stores there's
no crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of mystery fees
instead
mint passes on sweet savings and that we
do love some sweet savings here at new
rockstars and speaking of hearing the
rockstars philip
switched to mint and he loves it he kept
his phone in contacts and has great
service at a much lower rate and all
plans come with unlimited talk
and text plus high speed data delivered
on the nation's
largest 5g network and if you're not 100
satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee so switch
to mint mobile and get premium wireless
service
starting at just 15 bucks a month so to
get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com big q that is mint
mobile.com
big q cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month
at mintmobile.com big q
yes now let's talk about something i
love honey sweet sweet
honey baby hello my baby hello my honey
we've all seen the promo field
taunt us at checkout when we're shopping
online
thanks to honey manual searching for
coupon codes
is a thing of the past i hope you didn't
like doing that
because it's gone now thanks to honey
honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the depths of the internet
for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds
straight to your cart
you like that well i do too honey
supports over
30 000 stores online that's a lot of hot
topics
everything from gaming all the way to
food delivery doordash anyone remember
that
uh when you check out at one of your
favorite sites
the honey button drops down by the way
the honey button is what i call my belly
button
but in this case the honey button drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons in a few seconds honey
searches for coupons
and if it finds a working coupon you
watch the prices drop
off screen producer zach is a big honey
user and recently
he used it to save seven dollars on some
new shoes honey has found
it's over 17 million members over two
billion
dollars in savings that's billion with a
b so if you don't already have honey you
could
be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid
and supporting this show i never
recommend something i don't use
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
bigquestion that's joinhoney.com
big question all right baby it's time
for some bite-sized questions what do
you got for do it
okay tommy you ready for this you ready
oh i was born ready
the first bite-sized question of the day
is what is the biggest ship
in the star wars universe oh i'm so glad
you asked
yeah it's probably best if we stick to
the ships in canada
for this answer i mean of course we
can't do margin ships no more legends
ships you hoes uh there's lots of stuff
out there in the legends and expanded
universe
that could certainly compete for the
title of largest ship but we know fast
ships
like the falcon are fast enough for you
old man but
we have to bring it in somehow so now
we're going to look at actual starships
for the answer and it's not just space
stations and giant weapons so that means
no starkiller base which was basically a
giant laser
built into a planet by the first order
in the force awakens
a little bit like the death star and
let's be fair
we're also going to exclude the death
star even though the death star was
equipped with a hyperdrive
and sublight engines making it as mobile
as any other starship
uh it's still described as a space
station by obi-wan so
we're gonna disqualify it sorry blame
obi-wan if you want to get mad
send your emails to obi-wan yeah email
him
which doesn't exist he'll read it to
give you an idea of how big we're
talking here the millennium falcon is
about
35 meters long which is about 115 feet
going up from that a normal star
destroyer is 1600 meters long
but let's start getting big an executor
class
superstar destroyer also known as an
executive class
star dreadnought is 19
000 meters or 19 kilometers long
we first saw one of those in empire
strikes back dwarfing normal star
destroyers as it flew
overhead in the last jedi iconic
a very iconic moment in the last jedi we
got a sneak peek
at supreme leader snoke's personal ship
the supremacy
this behemoth is a big cl as a mega
class
star draw knot with a wingspan of 60
kilometers that's over 37 miles baby
that's it that's from that's la to long
beach okay
that's about 36 and a half more miles
than i can run yeah that's insane that's
37 more miles than i can
[Laughter]
so this is where the second death star
would come in as the champion of big
ships as it had a diameter of 160
kilometers
said we weren't gonna count it but i
changed the terms of our deal
pray i don't alter them again
this deal is getting better all the time
the death star reigns supreme only those
gang rebels hadn't blown it up and
killed all those independent
contractors that's brood rebels i got
i got another one for you you ready for
another one yes all right here we go
okay sacrifice question is how far is
asgard from the planet earth
tommy answer me that riddle me this
first of all asgard is not real
uh so it's not it's nowhere
uh no uh just kidding ashgard is real if
we believe it's real
yes asgard in this case the old asgard
destroyed by super was floating out
there in space
as part of the nine realms it wasn't in
another dimension but actually in our
dimension just really
really really far away from earth so if
you want to go to asgard in a spaceship
without a bifrost
how far would you have to travel it's a
little tough to say because we don't
know exactly where
in space asgard is in thor ragnarok
valkyrie tells thor that
sakhar and asgard are about as far apart
as any two known
systems she says she can take a wormhole
outside of the city
refuel on xandar and they can be back in
asgard in about 18 months
now well we don't know where sakaar or
asgard are in relation to earth we do
know where zandar
is it's in the andromeda galaxy which is
uh
2.537 million light years away from
earth just a hop skip and a jump
that's just a quick you know that's a
quick sunday drive we
can't do the math on how far zandar is
from asgard based on the 18 months at an
unknown speed that valkyrie states
but it would be fair to guess that
asgard is somewhere between 2.5
and 3 million light years away so if you
were traveling at the speed
of light it would still take at least
2.5 million years
to get dang to asgard
ah that means a quick trip on the body
frost must be a
wild ride because you are traveling
bro like that makes me think like
imagine if they developed like a bifrost
engine for like a for a spaceship so
that you can go even farther distances
that would be
nuts that's probably what ego has in his
little ship
when he's like traveling like super
super fast did he like teen wolf rides
on at one point
he's like riding outside they come out
cause we i think it's been revealed by
james gunn that ego is like literally on
the edge of
the universe so like he was going super
fast so like that was like
bifrost speeds and it even sort of looks
like the bifrost when it's when it's
traveling well not the sort of in a way
not really but like in the comments
there's some similar mistaken
that's great thank you for those
questions and now
you're welcome it's time for a little
segment i like to call
boxing that's the box of scratch there's
a box of scraps
it's the box of scratch what's the
question tommy ah
yes mt if you could replicate the
talents of any one person living and
dead
who would it be and why um so it's a
toss up for me because like
obviously i got my role models i do want
to be more like i love
i love me some dave chappelle i love
miso some conan o'brien
but uh given recent bs that has happened
in this world
yes i'm gonna have to say uh miss
shikari richardson
she is an athlete she is one of the most
impressive runners of all time and she
wasn't allowed to participate in the
olympics because she they found a little
bit of weed
in her bloodstream which is a whack
reason to disqualify one of the best
if not the best runner in the world in
her field so i'm gonna say shikari just
for
solidarity because i got my people yeah
so i got you shikari absolutely how
about you who would you want to
represent
i think similarly i would stay in the
world of sports
and i would try
i would want lebron james's athleticism
okay
because i think you know it's kind of
debated
one of the great sports debates is like
that lebron james could probably play
any professional sport like if he
decided that he wanted to be a soccer
player he could probably be
a u.s men's national team soccer player
seriously he has the body
of like he's just got genetic adonis
and i think being that physically fit
like the amount of like
things you could do or try i don't i
just
to spend one day inside lebron james oh
my god
phrasing tommy it's phrasing well that
is it for this episode of big question
thank you of course
to tommy for joining me for this episode
you can follow him at tommybechtold on
twitter you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet weird
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
and make sure to hit that notification
bell so you get notifications whenever
we upload
some dope take it easy guys stay
safe we love you bye
[Music]
you